you know other things about kevin
stefanski that i've figured out in just
one year
as an nfl head coach he will never
blame anyone but himself to the point
where
you can write the questions ahead of
time or the answers to the questions
he's always going to say i put that on
me
i take the blame he's conditioned to say
it to the point where
look i mean behind closed doors surely
he's laying blame but he's trying to
protect his guys from any undue
criticism beyond that which is going to
happen organically so
here's some criticism that would happen
organically for anyone who was paying
attention
to yesterday's game between the chiefs
and browns and i thought about this all
day before i've
really talked about it at length serene
or written anything about it i'll write
about it later tonight
the objective was simple and i heard
tony romo and jim nance talking about
this yesterday and sims and i
and i'm sure you and i talked about it
last week if you're the browns you slow
the game down
you keep patrick mahomes on the sideline
you have fewer possessions
per team if you want to limit the
scoring of the chiefs
but when mahomes is out that's when it
should flip
to more possessions not fewer i'll take
baker mayfield over chad mc
chad henny in a shootout any day and
that's what
stunned me when you look at the browns
getting the ball after the carl jovis
joseph west virginia great interception
in the end zone of course you or i could
have caught that ball
it was like a punt right joseph makes
the catch in the end zone with
exactly eight minutes left cleveland
starts on their own 20.
they they they they go three plays they
get to fourth in one baker mayfield gets
a first down yeah here we go
they take an ill-advised timeout and
then
they do three more plays and by the time
they punt there's only four minutes and
19 seconds left what the hell
three minutes and 41 seconds to move 12
yards you're moving as if you're putting
all your eggs in this drive
and then you punt and the argument for
the punt is easy we're punting it back
to
chad henny and the chiefs and maybe
we'll get the ball back well you didn't
first of all
and second if that's the mindset at that
point
force the issue force the issue move
faster and punt it once because then if
you stop them
you get another shot and if they stop
you you can punt it again and maybe get
it two more times it three more times
that's what i can't reconcile i
understand punting it on fourth and nine
from your own 32. i understand that
with chad henny running the offense even
though they obviously didn't get the
ball back
but that should have happened a lot
sooner on the clock
the punt moment and then you have your
shot to
to stop chad henny that that's what
bothers me the most about that
it's a great point mike and at that
point when chad henny does come in you
do try to maximize those possessions
you're behind you're not ahead you're
not trying to run time off the clock at
that point
and i also have a problem with the two
timeouts they burned mike the first
one was on that stupid tyree killed
catch and you could see if they had just
waited
just a few more seconds they would have
seen that he caught the ball
and not to throw the challenge flag and
not to cost you a timeout with 11
minutes left in the game
so that was the first dumb timeout the
second dumb timeout
comes as you said after that fourth down
play they let it run down at that point
you you probably should have taken the
penalty i'm not using my timeout at that
point
and why they came out of that fourth
down play not ready to go anyways
a separate question entirely but you end
up losing a yard if you had
taken the penalty it would have been
only four more yards and you would have
still had the timeout so just
two blown timeouts at that point mike
and then that whole they got behind the
yardage on that
loss of one then you're about then you
don't have a timeout you're down to one
time
out that whole series right there of
plays was just not a good series of
plays for the browns
and ultimately ended up costing them a
chance to have to go down and
and score because they did end up
punting and never got the ball back
this is what happens when you have a
limited experience
in the postseason and kevin stefanski
was with the minnesota vikings from 2006
through 2019.
they made it to the nfc championship
game twice they were in the playoffs
sporadically you know i don't know 40
of the time during his time there 33 of
the time not enough playoff experience
to really get into that into that zone
like you have to get into a sweet spot
you have to feel
fully in control of your faculties you
have to make good decisions
and you have to also know when to make a
calculated
risk like andy reid fourth and one there
is no tomorrow that's what he said today
this is a guy who's climbed the mountain
last year this is a guy who's been
around he knows
when it's time to go pedal the metal and
trust your guys to get a first down
and again i'm not saying fourth and nine
they should have gone for it but
i just i was stunned that they burned
off that much time and that it was so
easy
for the the chiefs to get themselves in
position to kill the clock and it was
that that uh
one there was one first down and then
the second first down on the third
it was the third and 14 run by chad
henny that left him short and the quick
pass to tyree kill and that was that
is that that for the los angeles rams as
it relates to quarterback
jared goff immediately after saturday's
loss to the packers
sean mcveigh had the press conference
walk-off where he was asked about the
quarterback and he said
jared goff is our quarterback right now
and it left us hanging it was like the
last episode of the sopranos cutting to
black like what the hell did he just say
what's going on here sunday he met with
reporters again
he was a little more explicit and
detailed about
the future and listen to this question
from reporters
and listen to mcvay's answer as it
relates to the future of jared goff
is there any scenario that you can see
where jared would not be on the roster
next year
you know like i said gary we're in a
situation that we're in evaluation mode
um you know all those things are things
that you know we're
moving forward we're looking forward and
and i can't you know
answer any of those questions until like
i said i take a step back and you
evaluate everything that
uh is in the best interest of the ramps
that's not how you answer that question
if it's a stupid question
that answer legitimizes the question the
only way
to avoid creating an issue that is going
to hover over the team
for weeks if not months if not years
depending upon how long they keep jared
goff
is by treating that question as a
ridiculous question
now you can do it in a polite way sean
mcvay's very schooled in the pr thing
always uses the name you heard hey gary
and
you know he'll he'll always use the name
he folds that in i'm interested to see
if brandon staley picked that up in his
one year with the rams and he does the
same thing and now
that he's head coach of the chargers but
there's a way to without being
a bill belichick style butthole there's
a pardon me
there's a way to answer that question
that doesn't legitimize the question
that's what mcveigh should have done if
it really is an illegitimate question
i guess there's a chance he accidentally
legitimized the question by being polite
but i'm i'm gonna take him for what he
said
and what he said is no one's guaranteed
a roster spot including the supposed
franchise quarterback
and if you have a franchise quarterback
mike you say
we have our franchise quarterback he's
our franchise quarterback for a reason
he's going to start
next year you put those questions to
rest
and he did not do that there is
absolutely question and you go back
a week mike when uh jared goff came
out and said he should have started that
his thumb was fine and he should have
started
in the wild card a playoff game and he
didn't start
there's a problem between those two
right now it's very obvious
that there's a problem between those two
guys and how they fix this in the
offseason i don't know but
there is a question about jared goff and
sean mcvay knows there's a question
about jared goff he has that same
question about whether he is their
quarterback of the future
and unfortunately mike they gave him
that big contract and it's going to be
tough for him not to be on the roster
right next season
well yeah because of the contract that
they gave him in 2019 and i'm going to
go back to june of 2019
because that's the time when we were
pushing this notion that at some point
a team is going to say to a quarterback
that it drafted
who is getting to the point where it's
time for a new contract and at that
point golf only had three years and he
had two years left under contract
somebody's gonna say no we're waiting or
no
we're not doing it we're gonna keep you
for five years
and then we're moving on and this was
the interview
by fred rogan of the nbc affiliate in la
because
he was very dismissive the idea and he
got mcveigh to be very dismissive of the
idea and here's the question that was
posed
consider the words used then in light of
the current situation with the rams
here's what fred rogan said i don't know
how often you check online and care what
the pundits say
one me suggested that you know the thing
about jared goff is there will be a
point in time
when you're just going to get rid of him
because you're going to bring in
somebody here who's younger and who will
be your kind of guy
now to me i thought that was insane
thanks fred because you've developed him
into one of the top quarterbacks in the
game
and here we are less than two years
later and
they shouldn't have paid jared goff they
should you know what if they hadn't paid
jared goff shireen
he'd be a free agent in march and who
the hell is going to give him 33 million
a year if
he becomes a free agent in march nobody
mike and they would have gotten him for
much cheaper if they wanted him back
which now is the question about what
they want to do with jared goff i mean
he had 20 touchdowns
and committed 17 turnovers this season
he was
not a quote-unquote franchise
quarterback he was not one of the top
quarterbacks in the game as
as fred referred to him a couple years
ago and he has a long way to get there
they have a great defense
but that defense as we saw can only take
you so far you've got to have some
offense mike to go with that defense
just because you get to a super bowl
doesn't mean you're a franchise
quarterback jared goff got to a super
bowl
not a franchise quarterback jimmy
garoppolo got to a super bowl
not a franchise quarterback and that's
that
and that's okay not everyone can be a
franchise quarterback
there's only 10 maybe i don't know
but not jared goff not jimmy garoppolo
too bad
maybe the jg maybe that's the giveaway
jason garrett you know maybe it's not
good to be in football with the initials
jg maybe that's the problem
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports